that's what they want according to
liberals all of politics is reduced to
economics okay I mean this of liberalism
on the Left what we call progressivism
or left ISM and I also think of that on
the right you know the kind of more
squishy conservative types the the
people who still view politics primarily
economically and during a pandemic
that's a good time to remember that we
are not primarily economic actors I mean
just consider just consider the New York
Times yesterday two days ago for
Mother's Day they put out this piece
forget pancakes pay mothers it's an idea
that's gaining currency on the left and
even a little bit on the right this idea
that that the state should pay mothers
to raise their own children one lesson
from the pandemic child care is work and
it should be compensated after just six
days of sheltering in place I found
myself thinking about all the women I'd
taken for granted so this woman Kim
Brooks writes I started with Griselda
who cared for my kids when they were
babies a few hours each week if someone
had asked me why I paid these women to
do things that I could do myself
particularly when I made so little money
with the time they freed up I'd say that
I did it because I wanted to work
because I needed to work not just out of
economic necessity but also out of a
need to feel like a full human being how
sad is that hypothetic that in this
liberal order we're told that the only
thing that matters is is your job your
court you making widgets as a middle
manager at widget Inc is so much more
important than raising children even
though the hand that rocks the cradle
rules the world that that's a novel
concept and obviously this woman has
bought it hook line and sinker
throughout my 30s I found myself largely
occupied with keeping a home and raising
children this work despite bringing joy
and meaning to my life shared many of
the qualities of the menial jobs I've
done before but but there was one small
difference the work I've done as a
mother I've done for free so she's
abroad it's like the compliment sandwich
you know it's brought a lot of joy
meaning to my life but actually it's
terrible and I hate it and you know look
we I've gotten paid for other work I
want to get paid for this work you
didn't do it for free you got chill
you got a family out of it that's the
pay that's a good thing that's a lot
better than making 15 bucks an hour at
the widget factory then she points out
that she had a she's been divorced with
attitudes like this okay
you know maybe not the most shocking
thing to learn
I mentioned this article because some
conservatives are embracing these kinds
of ideas they say oh maybe it's a good
idea where if the problem is that all
people are now being compelled to go
work at the widget Factory they're all
being compelled just to get jobs and not
raise kids maybe we need a new
government policy a new entitlement or
something to encourage women to raise
kids no you're being played for suckers
if you think that's what this is about
and this woman actually admits it she
says in 2012 the Marxist feminist
federer
Sylvia Federici published a collection
of essays ms Federici writes to say that
we want wages for housework is the first
step toward refusing to do it it makes
what's invisible visible and that's the
way it gives away the whole game it's
it's not the first step in returning to
raise children keep a home it's the
first step toward abolishing it all
together toward making this problem of
economic modernity even worse this idea
that we're all just cogs in a machine
even worse she says as I wrote this my
sweet daughter reminded me it was almost
Mother's Day you know and she's gonna
make pancakes and and then this woman's
unbelievable she says everybody likes
pancakes but everybody also likes to be
compensated for the contributions they
make to the world you are compensated
you have a family be happy have some
gratitude you know it's it's such a
ridiculous argument because they say pay
women a wage or Andrew yang said this
during the campaign what's the what's
the wage what's it worth you mean um
what what is what is the hourly wage or
the annual salary that that mothers
should be paid or the wives should be
paid for keeping a home pick a number
you can't because any number you pick is
going to be offensive there's no there's
no you couldn't go to the feminists and
say okay I tell you what you make 30
bucks an hour 30 bucks an hour is a good
good wage right they wouldn't be so
offended you think my work is only worth
30 bucks an hour what is a hundred
thousand dollars a year it's a 24/7 job
right if you look at it primarily
a job instead of as a life but there's
no price
what could the price be obviously I'm
not gonna get paid a salary to do what I
do as a husband I don't do all that much
around houses husband but I guess
there's some things right maybe
emotional support I don't know what do
you how do you quantify these basic and
ineffable aspects of our humanity how do
you quantify that you can't do it and
yet that's what these eggheads want to
do
[Music]
[Music]